join now from North London by Michael
Harris a friend of liras who set up a
GoFundMe page to help pay for her
funeral so far it's raised almost 30,000
pounds in just a few hours thanks very
much for being with us this evening you
have our deepest sympathies of course
we'll ask you about the GoFundMe page in
a moment but first of all tell me how
you knew lis room what sort of woman she
was I mean
Lara was just an absolutely amazing
human being she was I met when she was
24 she was already a full flight
investigative journalist she was
researching the murder of a Northern
Irish MP 33 years before and I had met
her because we were campaigning to
reform the law of libel in Northern
Ireland
so that journalist such as Laura could
get a could could publish without fear
of being threatened by light libel
actions so she had a strong moral
conscience she was a really strong
probably one of novel islands most
prominent advocates for gay rights she
was just a lot as she was a really
lovely person she was so warm quietly
spoken but with a sort of powerful
dignity and everyone that met her I mean
she was a lovely humble down-to-earth
but everyone who met her just just was
sort of you know taken away with her and
she was a kind of you see you someone
you that lots of people describes the
friend because she was so open and she
kind of was tireless in the campaign's
that she worked for yeah she certainly
does sound a remarkable woman what
prompted you to set up the fundraising
page so a friend of mine Podrick texts
me that the news this morning and I was
just out I was just absolutely
devastated and I just wanted to do
something I wanted to make sure that
that Lara could be remembered and so we
just set the page up within about 5
minutes got it got it out there on
Twitter and the response from fellow
journalists from people around the UK
Ireland the world has just been
absolutely amazing people
tribute to Laura in particular people
paying tribute to Laura's writing I mean
she wrote a letter to her 14 year old
self a few years back for went viral in
Northern Ireland about growing up gay in
Northern Ireland and that really touched
a lot of people so her journalism her
writing her as a person kind of just
inspired people to give the money and we
want to help her mum Laura was a carer
to her disabled mum so we want to make
sure that the funeral expenses are
covered and so they go from Me's there
it's gonna hopefully raise 30 thousand
pounds and hopefully we can also get
people to give a legacy so that other
investigative journalists such as Laura
in Northern Ireland are supported
because frankly is actually dangerous
being a journalist in Northern Ireland
at the moment well the the fund I think
is certainly going to exceed 30 thousand
pounds it's almost reached its target
you mentioned that letter a few moments
ago that she wrote to her 14 year old
self I've read that earlier I mean it's
very moving
she wrote you're going to join a scheme
that trains people your age to be
journalists for the first time in your
life you'll feel like you're good at
something you'll have found your calling
and she really did find her calling
you've talked about the investigative
journalism she wrote and she carried out
she wanted to make the world a better
place she really did and she thought
that writing about her experiences
writing to explain what was going on was
the way in which that she could that she
could sort of make a better better place
I mean her journalism she you know when
she was talking about the investigation
into the the death of the MP 33 years
before she faced legal threats at 24
years old and she stood up to them and
then she tried to campaign to change the
law in Northern Ireland I mean that
takes some guts and determination and
you know working with Irish she would
just endlessly be optimistic full of
life full of passion and she did want to
change Northern Ireland she cared really
deeply about Northern Ireland and the
people of Northern Ireland and she
wanted to use journalism as a way of
kind of getting past
the horrors of the past exposing what
had happened and moving on past the
charity to a the tragedy to a more sort
of a more progressive future and I mean
what's particularly sad is that I think
Laura would she she was she had a sort
of post sectarian identity she was of a
new generation of people in Northern
Ireland that viewed themselves as from
Northern Ireland but not Protestant not
Catholic you know not necessarily
British or Irish but had a new sort of
identity and for her to die at the hands
of the sectarian murder at the hands of
a terrorist I think is a is a is a it's
a horrible dark irony yeah I think we
would certainly all agree with you there
thank you very much for that tribute and
best of luck with the fundraising page
thank you